je trouve bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors de l'avis
de nombreux observateurs cette victoire
sans appel a été favorisée par le
boycott de quatre des principaux partis
d'opposition
sur neuf est ce que vous partagez cette
analyse alors pas tout à fait la
victoire d'alexandre gucci tx est liée
au fait que les promesses économiques
qu'ils avaient fait il ya quelques
années se sont avérées réaliser il avait
prévu en 2020 un quasi doublement des
salaires
en serbie les salaires sont passés en
quelques années d'un peu plus de 150
euros par mois à 450
il avait promis de l'emploi aussi d'ici
sur une période assez courte à courte
échéance et c'est ce qui a été fait
grâce à politique d'infrastructures de
nombreuses autoroutes pour était remplie
donc la province a massivement voté pour
lui par contre il est vrai que dans les
principales villes et notamment la
capitale belgrade le boycott était déjà
suivi par exemple belgrade
seuls 36 % des électeurs se sont
présentés donc le boycott a été très
important
deuxième point le boycott a été si vous
voulez fondée sur l'idée que le pouvoir
de l'ex en déroute fitch est un pouvoir
autoritaire et un pouvoir digne des
années 90
or ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai et
c'est là où la stratégie de l'opposition
qui a appelé à boycotter
c'est un peu fourvoyé puisque au
contraire aleksandar vucic s'appuie sur
une politique relativement moderne et
qui dit moderne actuellement d'immeubles
modernes aussi de contrôle des médias
par exemple et de contrôle de
l'opposition
donc vous voyez la politique de boycott
n'a pas mené les résultats escomptés
certaines ong estiment que la serbie
n'est plus une démocratie mais un régime
hybride
alors il faut faire attention
les ong qui disent ça sont des ong
on sait bien qu'ils sont pour la plupart
payé par les opposants à la serbie la
nuit un domaine démocratie des gens
soutenu par soros il faut faire très
attention mais il est vrai d'un autre
côté que tout mouvement populaire il ya
eu des manifestations par exemple très
importante encore cette semaine qui sont
pour un changement beaucoup plus rapide
du régime
tous ces types de mouvements sont
fortement contrôlée par le pouvoir pour
te pouvoir a su vraiment canaliser même
le mécontentement populaire
de là à dire que c'est une régimes
autoritaires nan mais c'est un régime
qui est allé vers un très fort contrôle
et de l'opposition et de certains médias
donc il est vrai que c'est un régime
qu'on peut qualifier de démocratie
confisquée
mais pas de régime autoritaire on sait
que alexander boutchichi soutenue par
l'occident qui le considèrent comme
capable de résoudre le différend avec le
kosovo ancienne province serbe dont
belgrade refuse de reconnaître
l'indépendance est ce que alexander
boutique peut mettre fin au conflit
selon vous alors ça c'est la question
principale puisque vous savez bien que
aucun parti même celui d'alexandra
ouchichi n'accepterait que ce qui fait
le coeur de la serbie le kosovo métochie
ne soient arrachées à la serbie et
donner un pouvoir mafieux le pouvoir à
ban est due qu'aux on élabore des
échéances très capitale puisque vous
savez que le nouveau président qui est
maintenant assis sur une confortable
majorité va aller cette semaine dans les
capitales européennes et en fin de
semaine pardon en fin de semaine à new
york
essayer de signer un compromis avec les
deux dirigeants albanais hashim thaçi et
ramos jardinage le contexte
international sur kosovo métochie a
changé les etats-unis ne sont pas pour
une indépendance pleine et entière et
même dans l'union européenne des pays
comme l'espagne ne soutiennent pas cette
indépendance donc exempts de vantch itx
fort de cette majorité va pour vous
vraiment et bien faire pression sur les
dirigeants européens et américains
étasunien pour essayer d'avoir un statut
qui est celui alors on parle beaucoup à
belgrade du statut de hong kong par
exemple c'est à dire d'une forte
autonomie mais pas d'une indépendance
merci beaucoup alexis trou d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur en géographie et
géopolitique spécialiste des balkans